[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
this is how the ending of the
ucla gonzaga game sounded
on gonzaga's radio affiliate uh
the color analyst is uh adam morrison
you'll hear him
say a few words and then he'll join us
here's the call to the right side of the
floor defended by kissbert now drives
leans in the runner comes up short
choosing the rebounds and puts it in
we're tied at 90. three seconds left
here suggs the other way pull up three
for the win
yes for the championship
game hey
let's bring in adam morrison the gonzaga
radio color analyst and uh one of the
great college basketball players in
recent memory
how do you think you sound on uh the
call there adam uh
i think i did okay i'm just glad i let
my uh
partner tom hudson get through that and
he battled through me screaming over the
top of him but uh
obviously that shot was amazing so it
was pure joy
were you jumping up and down i was
yeah and you know because i was
preparing for
you know second overtime and you know
that's when the the analyst comes in so
i'm like well maybe we should call
timeout i get you know i'm starting to
formulate like a
cohesive thought in my head and then he
obviously makes it so i was
yeah i was obviously pretty excited it
was cool cool moment i like the strategy
that mark had
a timeout didn't call the timeout
because his team
has practiced this that just get it in
quick don't let the defense set
and then you know sugg's got a great
look yeah no
you can see mick cronin too after they
make that he's calling for a double team
because you know you obviously want
you know the guard in that situation to
have to zigzag and take some time off to
make the shot further and more difficult
and you know i don't think the ucl ucla
players
played it bad it's just you're
automatically just running back
and so i think you're exactly right i
think fewee did a good job of just
letting that play kind of develop and
obviously jalen made a heck of a play
we practiced uh half quarters at gonzaga
in the shoot around the
day before the game so i guess it kind
of pays off that's why you do it give it
a chance
what's that feeling like game on the
line ball in your hands
uh it's pretty cool i've i've was lucky
enough to make a couple game winners not
not as big as that
i missed a couple too um it's cool it's
a it's a cool feeling to have
uh the trust in your teammates um
you know and if you're lucky enough to
hit some that you know the reaction
afterwards is
pretty special i hit a couple at home
but i also missed one in the tournament
my sophomore
year so that's a it's it's a
double-edged sword obviously so
um you know it could be good and bad but
uh you know if you're putting that
position and you're lucky enough to make
one it's pretty special
because you guys lost to ucla in the
sweet 16 back in 2006.
yeah yeah we lost and that was the you
know the amphibious
me crying on the floor game so yeah i've
been in that situation it wasn't a game
you know a game ending shot we missed
but uh
you know gut wrenching is uh an
understatement for that game so yeah
i mean i've been in both spots and
luckily for uh jalen and our fan base
you know he kind of i guess kind of put
that stuff to bed for us and
it was pretty cool moment for everybody
that i was lucky enough to attend and
obviously
people watching well we forget that
you're kids
so when you know people would see you
crying and then it
you know it wasn't a meme back then
because we didn't have them but
it's almost like you know this screen
grab of you crying
and you know people forget like you're a
college
kid like did it affect you though that
when you saw
you know how people reacted to that or
how you looked after you missed the shot
yeah no i think i it did that at first
you know
you know near exactly right it was was
21 22 at the time and
um you know it obviously followed me
into my mba career i mean it
it's uh difficult to
you know describe like what it's like to
have people talk and talk
about you like that and it's like hey
this is
you know if you watch all ncaa games
this is
a pretty normal reaction to losing and
especially the way we lost
but i think that year you know i was
first team all-american led the nation
in scoring so i think it was a little
bit more magnified just because of
the type of season i was having and the
coverage that we got
um so yeah that was tough
um but you know like i said um
you know jalen kind of put that stuff to
rest i guess but
um you know i i let that game go
probably
10 years ago if you ask me the same
thing five years five years after the
sweet 16 game i probably would have
declined the interview
you know what i'm saying really yeah
well it just
it gets it gets kind of old you know
sometimes just to
you know pick a scab i guess but uh it's
also like you know there was other
guys on my team too that felt the same
way i did and
um you know so you just got to move on i
guess but
that was 15 years ago so it's like hey
you know we did beat them in 2015 going
to the elite eight
that year i was a grad assistant on gu
staff then obviously we beat them
um you know the other night so i think
we can kind of
maybe move on from it as program to
program but i i understand what
you know the connection with it well i
think there's a mystery to you
like there was a fascination but also a
mystery there and then
i didn't know that you you know were
doing the color commentating
on uh yeah on the games like you know
that brings you back
in uh like it almost feels like you're
you're part of the team
uh again i i don't know if you feel that
way like do you feel like you won
in that uh game against ucla uh
no i mean in a sense it felt good
obviously but
i think it it it was better for our fan
base
because there's a lot of fans that um
you know
always supported me and and that year
was kind of the first year of
um us being like a national story or
the the program getting elevated to a
different level
and so i think that's always kind of
irked our fan base to kind of be the
butt into the jokes
aimed at me but towards them so you know
the the support i got
just from random people and stuff online
that's like you know that one's
it was great for adam to have that call
and then
kind of the monkey off his back in that
regards for that ucla game was
good uh was cool but you know
the best part for me was like you know
obviously
being able to experience that and watch
this team continue with the
undefeated season you know because it's
obviously something special but
you know i got to run into old teammate
of mine ryan hollands
before the game which was cool because
he played in that game
and then we were drafted together in
charlotte
and he knows what it means to me and
vice versa for him and his college
career and his basketball career
what that game mean uh man so it's cool
to run into him and
you know just you know say what up and
then just kind of be like hey man
it's kind of weird that these teams are
playing again and blah blah blah and
stuff so
i think it's more was more for the fan
base which was
obviously good he's adam morrison he's
uh doing the uh color commentating for
the zags the former
gonzaga forward um you got two nba rings
where are those rings
uh that they're at home in a safe you
ever bring them out
uh i've shown them to my kids and that's
about it
yeah i kind of just leave them in there
and keep them in a safe place but yeah
the kids get to see them that's about it
what's your favorite memory of kobe
bryant
oh man there's a bunch uh
you know just how he
just how tough he really was um you know
and everybody knows the mamba stuff but
i mean i've seen the guy break his
finger roll his ankles
and just live on the training room and
then go out and compete
he was always so nice to me too and and
so
yeah he just was such a tough dude and
when you were around it and saw his
work ethic and his drive to be better
every single day and i know everybody's
talked about but when you lived it and
seen it it was fascinating i mean he was
a truly a savant he was a smart man
he was always trying to improve his
craft and you know the ultra competitor
like cut his arm off just to win a
basketball game so i was just always so
impressed and
you know looking back now obviously when
he passed to be lucky enough to be
around him
you know and be on some special teams
where he was
you know the leader of those teams uh
what was your welcome to the nba moment
there's a bunch let's see um
i think i was playing portland my rookie
year and i was obviously from the
northwest so that
and you know i was playing in charlotte
so we only got to go there once and
i think i drove and shot like a weak
floater against lamarcus aldridge and he
put it in like the
18th row and their fans really liked it
because
there was a lot a lot of fans cheering
for me as well just being from
the northwest the year before but you
know there was a bunch because i was
obviously like i said i was in charlotte
and you know it was a newer organization
then and
you know i had older teammates that
would you know would be like hey this is
a little bit different than the nba and
i didn't really understand what they
meant then i get traded to la and i'm
like oh okay
what you meant so that that part was
kind of funny
uh you know but i hope you never feel
like you have to apologize for anything
adam
you know that oh i appreciate that yeah
no i like that
and you know i when i talk about the
ucla game and i really do mean it like i
put that stuff to bed
about 10 years ago you know what i mean
it's like okay
life goes on it's not it's one game it's
not the story of your whole basketball
career
but it was funny when michigan was
playing ucla we're doing our post game
and i looked at my partner tom hudson
i'm like
i sure hope michigan wins just so i
don't have to redo this
you know that's just the oddest truth
and you feel like it starts making a run
you zang starts hitting threes and i'm
like oh god here it comes
so yeah it's uh i appreciate that but
yeah i i understand that so but
coming from you i appreciate that uh
what do you think happens tonight
uh i think it's going to be obviously a
very good game
i think the key matchup for me is
mitchell and suggs if we can keep
mitchell out of the paint
i think he kind of keeps everything
going for
baylor he had those 11 assists against
houston so i think
suggs and mitchell is going to be an
interesting matchup if we can get out
and transition
um we'll be fine we leave the country in
transition baskets 34 percent of our
shots
total shots come in transition so if we
can get out and transition and gang
rebound i think we got a better chance
but this baylor team should be
undefeated as well so
i mean this team is without the covet
pauses is
fantastic they guard they can score at
82 points a game
they get good perimeter play so i think
it's going to be a tough one i really
think it's
to me it seems like a pick em in my
opinion so um i'm looking forward to it
and
um you know hopefully it's a good one we
had wally zerbiak on last hour and wally
said that
timmy is the smartest player in college
basketball
and that he's unstoppable in the paint
yeah it'll be interested to see if you
know baylor does a double team package
against them and i've always kind of
scratched my head this year when people
try to go single coverage against them i
mean even against the mobley
brothers who are going to probably be
pros the usc game he was single coverage
and he handled them pretty well i think
he had 24-25 so
i wouldn't be surprised if baylor shows
us a double team package but
i know you know opposing coaches always
get worried for you know like a because
he's a good passer and we cut from the
weak side and then a skip pass for a
wide open three but
um he's been playing fantastic so i
that's
one of the keys to the game for me is
you know what the coverage is when he
gets the ball in the post
well you know conserve your energy save
your voice
yes i have been and i got to say one
thing dan this is this is honest the
truth
so you know i grew up watching you on
the mothership right
so when i my in 06 my last year at
gonzaga i had a really good game against
uh university of washington you did the
highlight and you gave me an in fuego
so like you inviting me on the show and
getting the talk is
is pretty special so i appreciate it but
yeah
i got an infuego from dan patrick i'm
like boom career's done we're good
but i meant what i said adam i you know
you don't have to apologize and it been
it feels like
and you know and i hope it's not there
in your voice any longer you
you were a great player and you know
just because your pro career didn't
match what people thought you don't have
to apologize
for anything i appreciate that thank you
all right have fun tonight adam thank
you very much
yeah thank you that's adam morrison